reported because we have no idea how
long it actually is all we have is your
four-page summary which seems to
cherry-pick from the report to draw the
most favorable conclusion possible for
the president and in many ways your
letter raises more questions than it
answers I must say it is extraordinary
to evaluate hundreds of pages of
evidence legal documents and finding
based on a 22 month long inquiry and
make definitive legal conclusions in
less than 48 hours even for someone who
has done this job before I would argue
it's more suspicious than impressive
your conclusion is something we've seen
before in fact we've seen it in your own
legal writing in June 2018 you wrote a
memo as a private citizen and a former
attorney general to the Department of
Justice laying out the president's case
against obstruction of justice
your audition clearly went well I look
forward to reviewing the Mullah report
myself I know my constituents do as well
I understand that portions of it must be
redacted as a matter of law but my hope
is that you will stop there and bring
transparency to this process as soon as
possible the American people deserve the
facts now to you a 5fy 20 but request
the request provides a significant
increase for immigration judges and a
modest increase for most federal law
enforcement however it either eliminates
or
significantly cuts respected grant
programs at the Department of Justice
that really make a difference in our
constituents daily lives for example
your request significantly decreases
essential programs including the cops
program which advances community
policing on a state and local level
would be cut by 205 million dollars the
DNA initiative program which provides
grants to reduce the rape kit backlog by
ensuring evidence that could lead to
meaningful convictions does not sit on
forgotten shelves and that would be cut
by 25 million dollars and the juvenile
justice program which helps prevent
youth crime violence and reduce
recidivism which would be cut by forty
eight point five million dollars these
are simply unacceptable reductions I
look forward to a productive discussion
today hope you can shed some light on
how this budget requests can adequately
respond to the great million dollars
these are simply unacceptable reductions
I look forward to a productive
discussion today hope you can shed some
light on how this budget request can
adequately respond to the grave task the
Department of Justice and its grant
programs undertake daily thank you again
for appearing before us I look forward
to an open discussion and honest
discussion and address the many
challenges before us today thank you
very much thank you now Attorney General
Barr you are recognized to give your
opening statement we ask you please try
to keep it to five minutes and your
whole saimin will be included in the
record thank you Thank You mr. chairman
madam chair and ranking member at home
I'm pleased to be here today to present
to you the president's fiscal year 2020
budget for the Department of Justice and
I'm joined here today by the
department's chief financial officer
Assistant Attorney General for
administration Lee Loftus we look
forward to discussing how our requested
appropriations will help protect the
safety and rights of our constituents
and your constituents for two fiscal
years in a row the department has broken
records for prosecuting violent crime
the department has also significantly
increased prosecution of firearm
offenses and in fiscal year 2018
prosecuted more firearm defendants than
ever before as prosecutions have gone up
crime has gone down and in 2017 after
two years of increases violent crime and
homicide rates went down nationwide the
FBI's preliminary data for the first six
months of 2018 show a 4.3 percent
decline in violent crime overall and a
6.7 percent decline in murders and a 12
percent decline in robbery and burglary
compared to the first six months of 2017
in order to continue this momentum
president Trump has requested an
additional 137 million dollars for
violent crime and transnational
organized crime prosecutions as well as
a an additional hundred million for the
project safe neighborhood grants to
state and local law enforcement the
department also requests 5.8 million to
enhance violent crime and Firearms
prosecutions over the first two years of
the Trump administration we have also
gained ground against the opioid
epidemic which is by far the deadliest
drug crisis that this country has ever
faced the department increased the
number of defendants charged with
federal opioid related crimes by 28%
from fiscal year 2017 the fiscal year
2018 prescriptions of the seven most
frequently abused prescription opioids
are down more than 23%
since 2016 to the lowest level in at
least a decade and over the same period
the DEA has lowered the legal limits on
production of the active ingredients in
these opioids by 47 percent more
importantly drug overdose those deaths
may have finally stopped rising
according to preliminary data from the
CDC overdose deaths decreased slightly
from September 2017 to August 2018 but
there's a lot more work to be done and
that is why the President's budget
provides for 295 million to combat the
opioid epidemic including 18.2 million
for the FBI's joint criminal opioid
darknet enforcement initiative or J code
which is a team of agents that work to
disrupt and dismantle the sale of
synthetic opioids on the darknet the
president requests 11.1 million for five
new heroin enforcement groups that will
be deployed to DEA field divisions that
have identified heroin as the first or
second greatest threat in their area the
president also includes two million in
operational funds for the National
opioid initiative of our o sadef program
the President's budget also proposes to
permanently transfer 254 million from
the White House Office of the National
Drug Control Policy to the DEA for the
hyda area programs the high intensity
drug trafficking areas this change will
eliminate redundancies by placing this
program under the agency that leads our
drug enforcement efforts we know that
most of the illicit drugs in this
country came across our southern border
in the fight against an unprecedented
drug credit crisis border security is
imperative in fiscal year 2018 the
department charged more defendants with
illegal entry into this country than in
any year before at the same time the
department increased the number of
felony illegal reentry prosecutions by
more than 38% our immigration courts
which are under the Department of Josh
yes have also become more productive
under the administration since the
beginning of 2017 the department has
conducted an unprecedented surge in
hiring immigration judges the department
has hired more immigration judges under
President Trump than in the previous
seven years combined we now employ the
largest number of immigration judges in
history with 46% more immigration judges
than just three years ago that is having
an impact on immigration cases after
eight consecutive years of declining or
stagnant productivity between fiscal
year 2009 and fiscal year 2016 our
immigration judges have increased case
completions two years in a row in fiscal
year 2018 immigration judges completed
the most cases in seven years in order
to continue this progress the department
requests 71 million for 100 new
immigration judges an additional support
staff in fiscal year 2020 this would
bring the number of authorized
immigration judges to 634 which would
more than double the number of
immigration judges on board in fiscal
year 2016 given the fact that these
judges face a record-breaking 860,000
case backlog this investment is more
than warranted and with the crisis on
our southwest border the department
requests six million for our southwest
border rural law enforcement violence
crime reduction initiative which will
help law enforcement agencies serving
rural areas along and near the border to
fight rural crime the department also
plays a critical role in protecting our
national security and combating
terrorism and cyber crime and that is
why the president requests an additional
70.5 million to enhance the FBI's cyber
information sharing abilities and cyber
tools capabilities as well as 16 million
for our national vetting Center the
president requests an additional 18
million for the FBI to address
counterintelligence threats particularly
cyberattacks
threats from hostile foreign
intelligence services mr. chairman there
are many other issues facing law
enforcement that we could talk about
today but the bottom line is the more
than 112,000 men and women at the
Department of Justice are doing
important work and we ask for your
support thank you Tony general bar and
your confirmation hearings you say you
believe that very important a results of
the Special Counsel Muller's
investigation we share with Congress and
the public we agree on that
FBI director Ray the nation's top
counterintelligence investigator told us
last week he had not read the special
counsels report my question is with
regard to your March 24th and 29th
letter cieariy committees the special
counsel mullah or anyone and his team on
his team have a role in drafting them or
reviewing them in advance if you use any
of the summary documents prepared by the
special counsel and drafting these
documents 24th and 29th
we under the letter of the 24th
mr. mother's team did not play a role in
drafting that document although we
offered him the opportunity to review it
before we sent it out and he declined
that the letter on the 29th I don't
believe that that was reviewed by mr.
Muller or that they participated in
drafting that letter but to go back to
something you said in your opening
statement about the availability of the
report as I've said as you pointed out
since my confirmation I do think it's
important that the public have an
opportunity to learn the results of the
of the special counsels work and I said
then that I would work diligently to
make as much information public as I
could and available to Congress as I
could you will recognize that I'm
operating under a regulation that was
put together during the Clinton
administration and does not provide for
the publication of the report but I am
relying on my own discretion to make as
much public as I can now in my letter of
the March 29th I identified four areas
that I feel should be redacted and I
think most people would agree the first
is grand jury information 6e material
the second is information that the ice
the intelligence community believes
would reveal intelligence sources and
methods the third are information in the
report that could interfere with ongoing
prosecution's you will recall that the
special counsel did spin off a number of
cases that are still being pursued and
we want to make sure that none of the
information in the report would impinge
upon either the ability of the
prosecutors to prosecute the cases or
the fairness to the defendants and
finally we intend to redact information
that implicates the privacy or
reputational interests of peripheral
players where there is a decision not to
charge them right now the special
council is working with us on
identifying information in the reports
that fall under those four categories we
will color code the excisions from the
report and we will provide explanatory
notes describing the basis for each
redaction so for example if a redaction
is made because of a court order in a
pending prosecution will state that and
we will just we will distinguish between
the various categories this process is
going along very well and my original
timetable of being able to release this
by mid April stands and so I I think
that from my standpoint by the by within
a week I will be in a position to
release the port to the public and then
I will engage with the chairman of both
Judiciary Committee's about that report
and about any further requests that they
have let me just get one thing clear for
the record my concern during my opening
statement that when you reject something
we should know why the area falls under
that you say will happen yes sir
yes sir your March 24th letter indicated
that some actions the special counsel
investigated as potentially raising
obstruction of justice as concerns had
not been publicly reported well these
actions be identified in the report sent
to Congress
as things stand now I don't think that
they will be redacted so they will be
identifiable thank you
name is chairman mr. Turney general as
you know there is a serious humanitarian
crisis at the southern border in fact
the previous administration explicitly
noted that transnational organized crime
in Mexico makes the US border more
vulnerable because it creates and
maintains illicit quarters of border
crossings that can be employed employed
by other secondary criminal or terrorist
actors or organizations of course the
your FY 2020 budget proposes an
additional 18 million in resources to
help advance the fight against
transnational organized crime Oh
can you talk a bit about Department of
Justice and how it is address in the
smuggling networks that are in danger
and so many of the lives are being
smuggled and trafficking across the
southern border and particularly the
children yes sir the the problem we face
on our southern border is is really
unprecedented not just the the volume
and the makeup of the people coming
across from an immigration policy
standpoint but by the strength of the
criminal organizations in Mexico one of
the things that has changed a lot in the
30 years before prior where I was
Attorney General has been the
strengthening of these criminal
organizations in Mexico these cartels
that are not only getting not only
involved in multiple kinds of drugs and
the transportation of those drugs into
the in distribution in the United States
but also into human trafficking so
attacking those transnational criminal
organizations is a high priority the FY
2020 budget requests in
a total of 3.2 billion that is targeted
at dealing with these transnational
organizations and we're in Crete we're
seeking an increase of a hundred and
nine million dollars this year the we
were also seeking 29 million in
programmatic enhancements including 18
million to strengthen the FBI's ability
to monitor and target the transnational
organizations and 10 million to
strengthen DEA Zabur eight its judicial
Wire intercept program in Central
America and another 1.7 million for DEA
sensitive intelligence unit which is
targeting these groups and their illicit
trafficking in narcotics I personally
believe that an important part of
securing the southern border is to have
a barrier system on the border and I
think that that will help not only in
narcotics interdiction but also in
suppressing human trafficking and it's
an important part of our enforcement let
me switch gears just a minute one of the
most sacred rights as you know as
Americans is right not to be spied on by
the government a FISA order may only be
issued based on a finding by the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court that
probable cause exists to believe that
the target of surveillance is an agent
of a foreign power one of our colleagues
representative Nunez has referred eight
persons to the FBI for investigation
concerning alleged misconduct during the
rush investigation including the leak of
highly classified material and alleged
conspiracies to lie to Congress and the
FISA Court in order to spy on then
candidate Trump and other persons I
would hope the Department of Justice
will be giving these referrals
appropriate and prompt consideration my
question is now that President Trump has
been exonerated of Russia
Luke collusion is the Justice Department
investigating how it came to be that
your agency used a salacious and
unverified dossier as a predicate for a
FISA order on a US citizen the office of
the Inspector General has a pending
investigation of the FISA process in in
the Russian investigation and I expect
that that will be complete in probably
in May or June I am told so hopefully
we'll have some answers from Inspector
General Horowitz on the issue of the
FISA warrants or Jen really more
generally I am reviewing the conduct of
the investigation and trying to get my
arms around all the aspects of the
counterintelligence investigation that
was conducted during the summer of 2016
are you investigating who leaked the
existence of the FISA order against
quarter-page who what are you are you
investigating who leaked the existence
of a FISA order against quarter-page I
haven't seen the referrals yet from
congressman Nunez but obviously if
there's a predicate for an investigation
it'll be conducted thank you Thank You
mr. chairman attorney general bar
reports suggests that Special Counsel
mullahs report is anywhere between 300
and 400 pages long I'd be interested in
knowing how many discussions did you
have with the Deputy Attorney General
and other staff between receiving the
report and releasing the memo was there
discussion or debate about the evidence
and conclusions
how many staffers assisted you in
digesting so many pages of complex
information in such a short period of
time let me tell you what I'm getting at
that I find quite extraordinary you
receive
a very serious detailed report hundreds
of pages of high-level information
weighed the factors and conclusions at
length outline prepared edited and
released your memo in less than 48 hours
to me to do this
it seems your mind must have been
already made up how did you do it the
thinking of the Special Counsel was not
a mystery to the people at the
Department of Justice
prior to his submission of the report he
had been interacting he and his people
had been interacting with the Deputy
Attorney General and lawyers supporting
the Deputy Attorney General in his
supervision of the special counsel and
in that context there had been
discussions so there was some inkling as
to some of the thinking of the Special
Counsel furthermore on March 5th I
believe the deputy and I met with
special counsel Muller and his team and
had a preliminary discussion about the
report so we had an inkling as to what
was coming or direction and so even more
thinking within the department was done
about that over that time that was a
matter of weeks and then when the report
came and it came a approximately midday
on Friday the Deputy Attorney General
and I and our staffs worked closely for
the balance of that day Saturday and
Sunday
I didn't want to interrupt you that's
did the White House see the report
before you released your summarizing
letter has the White House seen it since
then
have they been briefed on the contents
beyond what was in you a summarizing
letter to the Judiciary Committee I've
said what I'm gonna say about the report
today I've issued three letters about it
and I was willing to discuss the
historic information of how the report
came to me and my decision on Sunday but
I've already laid out the process that
is going forward to release these
reports hopefully within a week and I'm
not gonna say anything more about it
until the report is out and everyone has
a chance to look at it I think there are
some relevant questions that I do hope
you could answer today sir on the
question of obstruction of justice your
memo stated quote while this report does
not conclude that the president
committed a crime it also does not
exonerate him yet president Trump has
publicly stated that this report is a
complete and total exoneration can you
tell us who is factually accurate and
will the release report include details
on the obstruction issue and why as you
noted the president is not exonerated or
will that information be redacted
I've already explained the information
that's going to be redacted from the
report the four categories that is
what's going to govern the redactions
and in fact the special counsel and his
staff are helping us select the
information in the report that falls
into those four categories but again the
report help you in a position as I said
within a week to release the report
people can then read the report I've
already promised the Judiciary
Committee's that I would appear as as
soon as they're able to schedule a
hearing after the report is released so
I'm not going to discuss it any further
until after the report is out could you
just explain for us I understand that
you were going to appear before the
Judiciary Committee but in that short
period of time it is very puzzling to me
that the 400 pages could have been
reviewed and the president states that
this report is a complete and total
exoneration who's factually accurate as
I say it's hard to have that discussion
without the contents of the report isn't
it and that's why I'm suggesting that we
wait until the report is out and I'm
glad to talk to people about it after
then and I'm already scheduled to
testify about that
I appreciate that in closing I just hope
that we as members of Congress are going
to have the complete report and have
discussions with you as to the accuracy
of some of the statements thank you for
appearing before us today and will we in
closing will we have the complete report
are you or are you going to be selective
as to what you give members of Congress
you mean the unredacted report mm-hmm no
the the first pass at this is going to
produce a report that makes these
redactions based on these four
categories and that's something that I
am hoping will be available to the
public as I said I'm glad to talk
a chairman Nadler and chairman graham as
to whether they feel they need more
information and see if there's a way we
could accommodate that well I do hope
you can accommodate members of Congress
who feel it's our responsibility to see
the complete report and I look forward
to continuing the discussion thank you
again for appearing thank you thank you
this is Roby attorney general bar and
assistant attorney general office thank
you so much for appearing before this
committee today to discuss the
president's FY 20 but request I would
like to focus on the department's
efforts as it relates to sex and human
trafficking in the fiscal year 2018 the
department initiated a total of 230
human trafficking prosecutions charging
386 defendants in convicting a record
526 defendants the department continued
its successful anti-trafficking
coordination team initiative working
with partners in the Department of
Homeland Security in the Department of
Labor in 2018 these Act teams saw a
significant saw significant prosecution
results I'm including increases of 10
percent 75 percent and 106 percent in
cases filed to finish charge and
defendants convicted we are another hat
sitting on the Judiciary Committee and
through that committee's efforts in the
last Congress we passed several pieces
of legislation working with the
Department specifically to close
loopholes within the Criminal Code and
make it easier for the department to go
after these folks that are exploiting
children and trafficking human beings
this is modern-day slavery it's it's
important for me as a member of this
committee and I suspect every member of
this committee I think I can say that we
all want to see section human
trafficking eradicated in this country
want to make sure that your department
has the tools that you need to do so the
director ray was here recently directed
some questions specific to this issue as
well and would like for you to address
for the benefit of all of us as we put
pen to paper in our appropriations bills
we know the successes but where the
deficiencies and how can we on this
subcommittee be helpful in making sure
you have every tool that you need Thank
You congressman human trafficking is one
of our highest priorities now in the
department and we have brought in an
exceptional prosecutor as an associate
Deputy Attorney General in the deputies
office with the portfolio of
coordinating the department's efforts
directed at human trafficking and are
setting up task forces around the
country that she works with I met with
this team within the last month received
a full briefing on their current
activities and I've asked them to come
back to me with a plan of action that
could take it to the next level and that
could include shifting some resources
within the department as well as seeking
some additional legislative legislative
provisions that would would help our
prosecutors so rest assured that I am
very focused on on this and will be back
to the committee and the Judiciary
Committee with proposals as to how we
could accelerate our efforts I certainly
appreciate that and I of course was
extremely disappointed that we were able
to get a package of bills through the
house by voice vote only to see them
fail in the United States Senate which I
know each of those pieces of legislation
have made law enforcement job much
easier I guess and I do appreciate to
all of the work that you do with local
law enforcement to make sure that they
have the tools and the resources that
they need in order to combat sex and
human trafficking and child exploitation
most children now have access to the
Internet and the Internet technology
affords children access to vast amounts
of valuable information and endless
sources of entertainment
however it also exposes children to
certain dangers most worrisome children
may encounter and oftentimes to actual
predators that use the internet to
identify and lure victims through chat
rooms instant messaging and social
networking sites so if you could with
the short amount of time that I have
left and I can revisit this if there's a
second round but what does this do G do
J's budget request bill do to safeguard
our children from these predators
specifically on the Internet well we're
requesting 81 million for oj peas
Missing and Exploited Children program
we have 30 million for Nick Nick we have
30 million dollars for the ICAC task
force's which are now in operating in
states we have 81 of them operating
throughout the country and then the
activities of the child exploitation of
the Senate II unit in the Department of
Justice those are the sort of the three
pillars of our effort and all together
it's approximately 90 million dollars
thank you I yield back Thank You mr.
chairman Thank You mr. Carter right
Thank You mr. chairman
Thank You mr. Attorney General for
appearing before us today I have
understood for quite some time now that
there are those in this country whose
favorite pastime is attacking health
care
but your decision as our new Attorney
General to throw the weight of the
United States Department of Justice
behind an effort to get the federal
courts entirely to invalidate the
Patient Protection and Affordable Care
Act as unconstitutional is breathtaking
it's it's uh it's unbelievable it stands
out your decision does for its breath
its scope its recklessness and its lack
of legal justification to invalidate the
Patient Protection and Affordable Care
Act if your efforts are successful
millions of Americans would lose their
health care tens of millions of
Americans would see the premiums for
their coverage skyrocket one of our
Republican colleagues in the Senate
Senator Collins put it best when she
wrote to you last week her letter was
dated April 1st did you get her letter
yes okay and you saw that she wrote your
decision to pursue this course of action
in the federal courts puts at risk not
only critical critical consumer
protections such as those protecting
individuals suffering from pre-existing
conditions but also other important
provisions of that law such as the
Medicaid expansion dependent coverage
for young adults age 26 coverage for
preventive services and the regulatory
pathway for FDA approval of biosimilar
drugs unquote the Department of
Justice's refusal to defend our law the
Patient Protection and Affordable Care
Act is distressing because of the harm
that it poses to the physical and
financial well-being of millions of
Americans and also because the OJS
refusal appears to be driven by
political considerations rather than
health care policy discussions or sound
legal arguments Attorney General Barr
you're not a healthcare policy expert
but your department is taking the lead
on attempting a massive overhaul of our
American health care system so I want to
make sure we agree on a few of the
top-line facts and let's go through a
couple of quick yes or no questions at
the outset number one have you conducted
or viewed an analysis to evaluate the
effects of do jay's litigation position
to overturn the age
da the effects on consumer costs and
coverage have you done that analysis or
have you reviewed one well when we're
faced with a a legal question we we try
to base our answer on the law on the law
so the answer is no and I here's the
thing I can't imagine that you would
take that kind of a dramatic drastic
action without even trying to evaluate
the consequences for the American
consumers the people using the
healthcare the people for whom these
premiums are paid but let's start the
processer do you mean through down the
event may I'm successful in this lawsuit
that you're supporting and the entire
Patient Protection and Affordable Care
Act is struck down millions of Americans
who currently receive health insurance
coverage under the law are at risk of
losing that coverage am I correct in
that I think the president has made
clear that he favors not only
pre-existing conditions but would like
action on a broad health plan so he is
proposing a substitute for Obama the one
that's going to come after the next
election you mean the one that will come
down if and when let me be the one to
inform you should the law be struck down
millions of people who get their
coverage through the ACA marketplace
would lose their coverage and tens of
millions more would see their their
premiums skyrocket in addition if you're
successful 12 million people nationally
and 750,000 people in my home state of
Pennsylvania who have coverage under the
Medicaid expansion would also likely
lose that coverage am I correct in that
sir do you think it's likely we are
going to prevail if you prevail well
you're devoting scarce resources of your
department or that effort are you not
Attorney General we're in litigation we
have to take a piss yes take position in
litigation and if you succeed that many
people will lose their coverage
nationally from Medicaid and 750,000
from Pennsylvania alone right I'm just
saying that if you think it's such an
outrageous position you
nothing to worry about let the courts do
their job if you six well my time is
that we'll come back to this yield back
mr. chairman
well Thank You mr. chairman and mr.
Attorney General thank you for being
here today for a couple of years at the
end of the Obama administration from
violent crime in America started to tick
up that means more robberies more
murders and more assaults I'm encouraged
to see that the FBI's preliminary crime
statistics that released in late
February showed this alarming trend is
being reversed can you tell me what is
the department doing that is working and
does your new budget add resources for
fighting violent crime
thank you sir the violent crime as I
said in my statement is one of our
priorities and making sure we don't see
a resurgent 2vile resurgence of violent
crime our base amount in the budget is
4.3 billion and we're seeking a hundred
and thirty eight million dollar
enhancement to that 120 would go toward
reducing violent crime in communities
and 18 would be to Steffes step up our
efforts against these transnational
criminal organizations the flagship one
of the flagships of our fight against
violent crime is our project safe
neighborhoods now this is really a
concept that's been around for a while
under various guises but fundamentally
what it is it is a strategy to focus on
high crime areas that brings together
the local community the law enforcement
including federal and state and also the
various social programs and social
agencies that that run and fund programs
that are meant to to prevent crimes from
occurring and they have had a tremendous
record there have been studies showing
how it has suppressed crime in the where
it's been deployed we are seeking a 100
million dollars to to increase go from
20 million to a hundred million to to
extend the project safe neighborhoods
program we also are seeking ten point
seven million to its to expand
ATF's Nibin program which has proved to
be a tremendous tool in the fight
against violent crime this helps us
identify firearms when they're used in
crime and trace it back to particular
individuals so those are those are some
of the the main initiatives we have
underway to to grapple with violent
crime and and so far it looks as if
they're successful
I definitely agree our local police
chiefs and sheriffs really support the
project safe neighborhoods and and it's
a great program with a high return on
investment for helping reduce gun and
violent crime in our in our communities
also important to the state of
Mississippi is the addressing human
trafficking I know the state legislature
has been working really hard on it I
know my colleague miss Roby has asked
you some questions and I want to just
talk a little bit about I know the DOJ
undertook a us-mexico bilateral human
trafficking enforcement initiative to
combat trans-border trafficking can you
speak on this initiative specifically
how effective has it been and stopping
trafficking across the border yeah
I'm gonna have to get back to you that
Congress but I'm I really would have to
talk to people to see whether it's
having an impact at this point okay with
my limited time I'll jump over to
address some of the issues that with the
crisis that we have on our southern
border I know we have a immigration case
backlog there over eight hundred and
twenty thousand immigration cases
pending nationwide with the past 12
consecutive years seen an increase in
the number of cases this year's budget
request includes an additional 72
million to hire 100 new immigration
judges in your testimony you mentioned
that additional reforms are necessary to
manage the backlog of cases what reforms
does the Department of Justice need to
manage the case backlog and what can
Congress do to help you better manage
the backlog right an inauguration day
there were 306 immigration judges today
we have 424 one of the problems we had
was the long lead time of hiring these
judges which we've now cut from 2 years
to 6 months so it only takes six months
to on board and a judge currently there
are five hundred and thirty four slots
authorized and we're asking for a
hundred more slots so we'll be going up
to six hundred and thirty-four if that's
approved the backlog however we are not
making progress right now
against the back log our productivity is
increasing so that for example in the
first quarter of this year nineteen
thousand cases were completed however
during that same time twenty-six
thousand new cases emerged so we
actually lost ground in the first
quarter as we bring on more judges we're
hoping that we're actually going to
start working down that backlog but
until we can get some control of the
inflow we're not going to be able to
work down that backlog and the inflow is
a function of a number of factors the
problems with the asylum laws and
applying the siloam laws is one of the
chief factors the fact that they can be
gamed and when people are then released
the catch and release situation so when
people are released into the country and
never show up again that that prospect
is what's drawing people up from Central
America and also of the fact that so
many children are now included in that
population
so we need to have reform as the
president has said repeatedly we need to
have reform of the immigration laws and
we need to do all we can to discourage
people from making the journey up to the
United States by mechanisms such as a a
border barrier system
Thank You mr. Attorney General and thank
you Assistant Attorney General Office
for being here today and for your
service to our country I don't have a
question about the substance or
redactions of the report but I do want
to know was the President or anyone at
the White House alerted in advance of
your letters release the March 24th
letter I don't believe so but as I said
once the report is out I'll be
testifying and I'll be glad to discuss
all aspects of the process and also
explain the decisions I've made did you
or anyone on your team consult with
anyone in the White House in the
crafting of that letter are you talking
about the March 24th letter the answer
to that is no but as I say I'm not going
to discuss this further until after the
report is out okay so they did not have
to approve for you to release the letter
the White House thank you
I do want to ask my second question and
if you could answer yes or no just in
the interest of time running out of time
does the DOJ under the Trump
administration consider the enforcement
of the Voting Rights Act a priority
chief Roberts himself has stated that
voting discrimination still exists no
one doubts that
yes we do we consider voting rights a
priority has the DOJ the Civil Rights
Division brought any cases under the
Trump administration to enforce section
2 of the BRE no but I would point out
that during the first four years of the
Obama administration one case was
brought so well according to your
website the Department of Justice under
Obama both President Bush's and
President Clinton had brought at least
over 30 cases and enforcement of section
2 of the Voting Rights Act secretary
Ross credits the Department of Justice's
need to enforce section 2 of the Voting
Rights Act for the reason why a
citizenship question is needed on the
census the DOJ has been enforcing the
Voting Rights Act for over 50 years
without the need for a citizenship
question is there what what are your
thoughts on that my thoughts are that
it's being litigated right now and I
think oral arguments on April 23rd so
I'm not going to discuss it okay I
wanted to also ask about zero tolerance
policy do you agree with your
predecessors zero tolerance policy
memorandum issued last year April 2018
well there's a lot of misunderstanding
about the zero tolerance policy the zero
tolerance policy is that the department
would prosecute cases that are referred
to the department and the thing that
caused family separation was the
referral of cases to the department that
involved families with children I
theoden's put out an executive order I
believe saying that we're not going that
DHS is not going to follow that policy
and as far as I know we are not getting
referrals of that type but the general
proposition that the Department will
prosecute
cases that are referred to it stands
according to an article in The New York
Times yesterday president Trump has been
pushing to restart this practice of
separating parents from their children
the term binary choice policy has
certainly been getting traction is that
something that you support I haven't
heard that you haven't heard that no we
can submit articles to your office are
you aware of research showing that
separation from initial stages to
ongoing and long term is devastating and
detriment o to children's health and
development I'm sorry can you repeat
that
do you are you aware of any research
that shows separation of families and
children are detrimental to their health
I mean I haven't reviewed that research
but as I said the president has already
put out in order stopping the separation
of families so what you enforce and put
forth policies of new discussions that
have been happening about President
Trump wanting to restart this separation
practice well I can say I personally
sitting here I'm not familiar with those
discussions
what would you support continuation of
separation of families I I support the
president's policy which is we're not
going to separate families so you
support that we will not separate
families anymore thank you I yield back
mr. graves thing miss chairman during
general thanks for being with us and you
know I'll just remind the committee you
know we've heard a lot about the molar
report today 22 months of Investigation
2,800 subpoenas 25 million dollars in
from taxpayers 500 witness interviews 19
lawyers 40 FBI agents and who knows how
many warrants and the conclusions were
simple no collusion no obstruction I
remember when the first letter was
released and there were a lot of
complaints then attorney general that
you weren't releasing the summary soon
enough and then here today I hear it was
too hasty too quick so now you've had
time to review your team's had time to
review you've indicated maybe within the
next week we'll get the report released
so for the committee is there anything
new you've seen since the review the
entirety of the report that would change
your conclusions no congressman as I
explained my March 24th letter was meant
to state the bottom line conclusions of
the report not summarized the report and
I tried to use as much of the special
counsels own language as I could but
they were just stating the bottom line
conclusions and there's nothing to
suggest to me that those were you know
collusion or snow obstruction includes
over done so the letter the letter
speaks for itself I thought it did too
well shift him second because you know
members of Congress have said they
intend to ignore the public redactions
and and leak the full report would that
give you pause if that were to occur
someone's gonna leak the full report
that's that's what we the partners have
been saying well that would be
unfortunate because you know there's
grand jury information in there that
under the law has to be redacted
we've heard members of this committee
today say that the American people
deserve to see the full report and so
even members of this committee have
indicated that the chairman of judiciary
just this weekend said that this is
chairman Nadler
certainly some of it would not leak
publicly that he has discretion and in
the committee has a very good record of
protecting information which it decides
to protect so general bar under under
federal law does a member of Congress
have the power to arbitrarily decide
what portions of the special council's
report they might release redacted or
not a lot of it not if it violates the
law and we believe 6e does apply to
members of Congress so you know I it's
interesting because this whole mechanism
for the Special Counsel as I said was
established during the Clinton
administration in the wake of ken
starr's report and that's why the
current rule doesn't says that the
report should be kept confidential
because there was a lot of reaction
against the publication of ken starr's
report and many of the people who are
right now calling for a release of this
report were basically castigating Ken
Starr and and others for releasing the
Starr report I have already said that I
think the situation here requires me to
exercise my discretion to get as much
information out as I can and I think
these categories I think most
fair-minded people would agree are
things that have to be redacted right
and I guess just thinking about the
chairman Judiciary he if he were to
release or any member of Congress were
to release the full report or redacted
portions of the report are they in
compliance with law or in violation of
the law and wouldn't I would want to
speculate about all the circumstances
that would be involved I I don't intend
this at this stage to send the full
unredacted report to the committee so
I'm not sure where he would get it and
then just he got it directly from the
counsel that would be unfortunate I got
that what happened a quick question
about subpoena I'm not only Judiciary
Committee my understanding is though
they've issued a subpoena to you to
release the full report would that put
you in violation of federal law I are in
situation I don't think
I have the latitude to release 6e
material as to the other categories as I
said I'm willing to discuss those with
the Judiciary Committees I want a status
with try to accommodate and satisfy
their interests but at the same time
uphold the law and right now and there's
been a recent case decided in the
District of Columbia just I think within
the last week on this the 6e material is
not releasable well thank you for your
fashion in which you've handled this I
think you've been upright you've been an
example of integrity and and and I know
that you are going to abide by the law
and my hope is that all members of
Congress would follow lights like kind
so thank you Attorney General for your
good work it's the Christ Thank You mr.
chairman
Thank You Turney general bar for being
with us today on the question of
obstruction of justice you stated in
your March 24th letter that the model
report does not exonerate the president
can you elaborate on what is meant by
does not exonerate the president I think
that's the language from the report
right I understand that that's that's a
statement made by the special counsel
right I reported as one of his bottom
line conclusion so I'm not in a position
to discuss that further until the report
is all out and then what is meant by
exonerate is really a question that I
can't answer what he meant by that but
as you sit here today
you you can't opine after having read
the report yourself why it reaches that
conclusion that it does not exonerate
the president
right
reports have emerged recently general
that members of the special counsels
team are frustrated at some level with
the limited information included in your
March 24th letter that it does not
adequately or accurately necessarily
portray the report's findings do you
know what they're referencing with that
no I don't I think I think I suspect
that they probably wanted you know more
put out but in my view I was not
interested in putting out summaries or
trying to summarize because I think any
summary regardless of who prepares it
not only runs the risk of you know being
under inclusive or over inclusive but
also you know would trigger a lot of
discussion and analysis that really
should await everything coming out at
once so I was not interested in a
summary of the report and in fact at the
time I put out my March 24th letter
there was nothing from the special
counsel that wasn't marked as
potentially containing 6e material and I
had no material that had been sanitized
of 6e material so I felt that I should
state the bottom line conclusions and I
tried to use a special counsel Muller's
own language in doing that yes ma'am
yeah I'm curious did you feel that there
was an obligation upon you your office
to prepare this four letter overview if
you will rather than summary rather than
having the special counsels team do it
themselves why did that happen I guess
is what I'm trying to find out
it happened because the the special
counsel was providing the report to the
Attorney General and I was making the
decision as to whether to make it public
or any part of it public and in my
judgment it was important for people to
know the bottom line conclusions of the
report while we worked on necessary
redactions to make the whole thing
available
let me ask that unfortunately you know
that's a matter of weeks and I don't
think that the public would have
tolerated and Congress would not have
tolerated at least knowing the bottom
line and as you know from your own
experience from a prosecutor standpoint
the bottom line is binary which is
charges are no charges indeed did you
contemplate having the special counsel's
office help you with the preparation of
your March 24th letter or did you we
offered to have Bob review it before
putting it out and he declined I didn't
ask you about reviewing I asked if you
thought about having them help prepare
the March 24th letter I mean they they
didn't I didn't order after oh no I
didn't think why not because it was my
letter
you
you said that the Special Counsel and
his team were not shown or did not
review the March 24th letter right you
offered to let him review it yes did you
offer to anyone else to let other people
review it besides a Special Counsel not
that I recall I mean outside the
department anywhere yes outside the
department let's start there well the
answer I'm pretty sure is no but you're
not sure I am sure okay
you
Nicko yield only have 15 seconds Thank
You general
ace Thank You mr. in general I'd love to
talk to you about your 2020 budget but
what is far more critical at president
and it's what has much far more reaching
consequences to the credibility of our
government is the prompt and full
disclosure of the illah report the
current non-disclosure of that report is
only worse than the pervasive distrust
of government generally and of mr.
mother's investigation and your
department's response to it specifically
this really started very early on in the
investigation with excessive secrecy
about exactly what we were taking a look
at here is the Supplemental memo from
from the deputy acting Attorney General
and this is what drives the public crazy
when they see something like this this
is what we have to try to avoid when we
get into this in your March 24th a three
and a half page summary of the report
you stated that you are quote mindful of
the public interest in this matter and
that you intend to release quote as much
of the report as you can consistent with
applicable law regulations and
department policies you know you know of
course it on March 14th the house
resolved unanimously for 22 zero all
members of this committee and house
voting that the full report be released
publicly except where prohibited by law
and be released to Congress
unconditionally do you appreciate the
importance of a full disclosure of this
report both personally and on behalf of
your department I appreciate the
importance of releasing as much of the
information in the report as I can
consistent with the law okay well let's
get into that then what specific laws
regulations and department policies as
you've cited in your letter do you claim
require or justify you to withhold
portions of the report you've already
talked about 6e yeah what else well as I
said there there are four categories of
information that are being redacted I
understand that sir there's one of those
ask what else the other one is we've
asked the intelligence community to
identify any information that could
reveal intelligence sources and methods
for what authority do you have to to
state that you have discretion to rehaul
withhold I get the grand jury side
that's 6e and by the way you know as
well as I do that 6e also encompasses an
intelligence a committee except
exception so I assume you're gonna say
that that falls under that category that
that there can be some release are
withholding of intelligence specific
information under your 6e category what
about the other two categories what
justifies you in in claiming the
discretion to withhold that information
well are you talking about the
intelligence and no I'm talking about
I'm talking about the other two
categories I'm talking about ongoing
prosecution's but I'm particularly
focused on privacy and reputational
interest because it seems to me that
that's an exception that you can just
drive a truck through so I mean you're
the one that says you have the
discretion to do that and I'm asking you
where does your discretion lie where is
regulation because the regulation that
sets up the Special Counsel and also
provides for his report to the Attorney
General and also what the Attorney
General can release specifies that it
has to be consistent with the
department's long-standing policies and
the department's long-standing policy
and practice is that if we're not going
to charge someone we don't go out and
discuss the bad add or derogatory
information about them that's what got
everyone outraged and what the FBI
director Comey did in the case of
Hillary Clinton okay so the regulation
back to long-standing policy is what
justifies that exception right and your
in your view the regulation that says
that any release has to be consistent
with that okay good
let's go to 6e here for a second well
before I get to six of you are you
maintaining or will you maintain any
right to withhold any of the information
in that report based on a so called
claim of executive privilege
am i what are you going to claim that
you have a right to withhold any of that
report based on a so called claim of
executive privilege any claim of
executive privilege would have to be
asserted by the president and he the
president said as I said in my letter
which sort of speaks for itself he has
said that he's leaving the decisions up
to me okay are you going to claim
executive privilege to keep any of that
report back as I said there's no plan I
have no plan to do that okay
do you believe that executive privilege
applies to any broader range of
communications and specific direct
communications from the president you
know I would I would have to review the
latest opinions from OLC about the
precise scope of it but it's not
relevant to me right now
and as far as you know does it apply to
any communications by the president
before he was president as I say I'm not
sure what the learning is in the
Department of Justice on that
you're aware that some of the except
that there are exceptions under 6e under
which you can in fact disclose Grand
Jury material some of those are within
your discretion but many of those are
subject to a ruling of a court correct
what are they well there's six six e
there's five exceptions in 6e that allow
you to go to court to ask the court for
permission to release those it's up to
the court to decide whether to release
are you intending to go to court to ask
for guidance and our direction and or an
order where you are uncertain whether
you can in fact release or should in
fact release materials oh but I mean the
chairman of the Judiciary Committee is
free to go to court if he feels one of
those exceptions is applicable the right
is yours to ask for these digestions
well because you are the exercising
authority under 6 e yeah but I think if
the Chairman believes that he's entitled
to receive it he can move the court for
it well I'll come back to this it's your
right to ask so I'm asking what is your
intention my intention is not to ask for
it at this stage I mean if the Chairman
has a good explanation of why 6 C does
not apply and his need for the
information I'm willing to listen to
that
as I say my first agenda item here is to
get the public report how what can be
gotten to have publicly that's going to
be within a week
so I'll come back I'll just I'll discuss
these issues in greater detail after
that occurs miss Lawrence Thank You mr.
chair
Attorney General according to recent
reporting the Trump administration is
pursuing far fewer civil rights cases
including hate crimes police bias and
disability right cases than the Obama or
Bush administration's the DL J Civil
Rights Department has started 60% fewer
cases against potential violations
during the first two years of the Trump
administration then during the President
Obama administration and 50% fewer than
under the George Bush administration can
you please provide me why that is
happening and what are you planning to
do to address that I'd have to see those
figures and how they're broken down I
haven't seen those figures before the
areas that I'm familiar with such as
hate crimes it's simply not true we have
an enviable record of prosecuting hate
crimes at the same or higher rate than
previous administrations as far as I'm a
winner I'd have to see what other what
else you're talking are you familiar
with the data of what the percentage had
they increased under the trump
administration I think there are
indications they had they increased yes
hey whether hate crimes versus the
prosecution of hate crimes hate crimes
have they increased under this
administration I haven't seen any data
you know going from 2006 so is it a
priority you haven't looked at the data
you're not aware of it I as I said in my
my confirmation hearings I'm very
concerned about eight crimes and intend
to vigorously pursue them the data that
I have seen have showed an increase
going back to 2013 so I do I agree with
you that they have been increasing but I
don't
I have seen no data to say that it's
it's different under the Trump
administration Attorney General I want
you to we use the word stay woke
sometime and community activism where
you are in tune what's happening on the
ground
I appreciate your tenure or your length
of time that you've been Attorney
General but I can tell you that this is
something that's very important and I
expect for you to be informed and aware
of what's happening in this area I
wanted to follow up on a question that
my colleague pyrite asks cuz I I really
need to ask this question I watched with
in deliberate intent of your answers
when who do you report to
the President of the United States or to
the people of America you doing your
confirmation without duress said you
report to the people but you just said
when it came to the ACA ruling that you
gave that the president was very clear
that he opposed it and so let it work
out and legislation I want you to be
very I want you to be very let me finish
my question because that's what I heard
maybe you need to clarify it I want you
to explain to me
do you understand your role when you
issue a statement abolishing Affordable
Care Act that you as the Attorney
General of the people of the United
States have a responsibility to
understand and support that decision not
based on the policy of a President of
the United States
it was clearly laid out the impact it
will have and I want you to respond to
that because that's what I heard sir
well if you if you did listen to my
confirmation I did sir okay are you
distinguished between three different
roles the Attorney General plays one is
in enforcement another is in
policy role and the third is in
providing legal advice and what I said
then is that the Attorney General has
the responsibility to provide straight
from the shoulder legal advice as to
what the Attorney General thinks is the
right view of the law so in this case of
ACA you felt it was the right decision
under the law to issue that you support
abolishing well the Affordable Care Act
that's your legal well I didn't you
didn't let me finish which is that the
the first obligation is to provide your
best view of the law if the president or
your executive branch agencies that
you're representing and have our
stakeholders and the issue disagree with
that advice and and want to pursue a
different position then the Attorney
General litigating on behalf of the
United States should take that position
if it's reasonable and defensible legal
though even if it's not the position
that the Attorney General would take if
the Attorney General was a judge that's
that's the position I stated at my
confirmation hearing so I can be clear
so what you're saying is that if you
disagree with the president if your
legal experience and your expertise
doesn't agree and your president says
something different you're obligated to
agree and enforce what the president
says is that what you're telling me as
the Attorney General of the United
States of America well is that is that
your statement so it's the same as when
we represent and are defending a law of
Congress sometimes we don't think the
law is an original matter actually sir
we pass laws the president the United
States do not pass laws right but I'm
saying that but if but I feel that if
there's a reasonable and defensible
argument that could be made to defend a
statute we frequently do that sir I'm
concerned at this point I'm over my time
and I will come back at my second that I
am very concerned with your statement
thank you
you
general in your testimony you said
violent crime has declined since 2016
but as we learn from the FBI homegrown
violent extremism has grown over the
same time what priority and resources
have you included in the 2020 budget to
counter such violent extremism I don't
think we breakout maybe you can help me
I don't think we break out the budget
targeting that particular category of
offense we do not have a separate
category for violent extremism but we do
pursue all matters of violent crime
together and we have the 138 million
dollars in 135 new positions for our
violent crime efforts and the FBI we're
adding 47 new FBI agents to the FBI for
a variety of new initiatives and among
them is the FBI's work on violent
extremism okay it's important for this
committee to know at a certain point how
many folks will be assigned to this so
how many dollars will be assigned to it
because it is an issue that concerns all
Americans I believe and we need to deal
with it in a way yes mr. chairman but
you know the people who are on the watch
for this kind of thing whether they be
FBI agents or US Attorney's pursuing
potential cases or the very same people
that would also be looking at other
forms of terrorism potentially so it's a
little it's hard to allocate exactly the
dollars by that category but you know
obviously it is a serious issue and it's
one that the FBI is devotes a lot of
effort to well as long as we know that
the Department the agency is looking at
it is dealing with it is seeking it
seriously we can then work together on
it that's that's easier part mr.
chairman if I can add a bit more
we do have an FBI
as budget this year we have the 16
million dollars for the FBI's
participation in the national bedding
center with other federal entities and
that helps the FBI look closely at
individuals who may be coming to the
United States so we have that vetting
money and in the FBI we also have four
million dollars in the office of Justice
programs on grants to go towards looking
at extremism and domestic terrorism a
few weeks ago the ATF director Brandon
told us at the department's fiscal year
2020 budget request would result in ATF
being forced to let go more than 300
staff due to increasing investigatory
cause as we seek to address rising gun
violence of this nation how can the
department justify a proposal that will
result in fewer resources dedicated to
that goal let me just say first that I'm
a huge fan of ATF I think they're an
outstanding agency and I would love you
know any money spent on the ATF as well
is well worth it one of the common
themes I hear from US attorneys is how
valuable the ATF agents are and their
technology is just outstanding and
helping to deal with gun violence and
and violent crime now I am told that the
statement made by mr. Brandon was
actually based on faulty information and
we don't think that it would lead to we
are asking for more money for ATF and
and we don't think it would result in
fewer agents but you know maybe Lee
could help me with that so I think very
highly of the ATF chief I've known him
for years we've worked together very
very closely we took a hard look at his
budget this year's budget will increase
ATF by three point nine percent actually
just about four percent it does have
increases for ATF if you look back over
the last three years we've given an
eight point seven percent increase to
ATF so we do think ATF is important
we are trying to support ATF I know the
ATF chief is very concerned about his
agency is his budget is susceptible to
absorbing inflationary increases and if
the pay raises and funded or or if his
rents or contracts go up he's very
concerned about that he's worried that
it'll translate into a loss of staff I
can tell you that we have looked at this
year's budget though and at the 4%
increase we're asking for we don't think
that translates into loss of hundreds of
staff and our commitment is that we want
to work closely with ATF make sure they
have what they need as the Attorney
General says any resources ATF receives
I think will be put to very good use but
we're committed to working closely with
the ATF folks to make sure they make it
through the year and again a four
percent increase on this budget we think
is a strong request for ATF strong
request for their Niveen system the 11
million for that there's four million
dollars for their spartan case
management system so we are trying to
stand behind ATF in this budget well I
would hope that you can get this issue
resolved in terms of letting us know
what really is going on because as we
put together the bill and that will
happen pretty soon you know I need to be
able to go to those it's young woman on
my right and tell her I need more money
or or for certain agencies and we can't
do this if they're saying they're gonna
lose over 300 folks and you'll say
they're not or that it's not
we need that picture cleared up
absolutely and we'll help you thank you
miss at home thank mr. chairman and
corsa the Department of Justice has
submitted a almost 30 a billion dollars
taxpayer dollars to use and I won't
remind my colleagues that that is what
this perp the purpose of the Attorney
General being here today is to talk
about that 30 billion dollars that's of
taxpayer dollars going to be used and
unfortunately I I see so many of the
questions here this morning have gone
toward going toward a grassy no
conspiracy theory regarding with the
Mueller reports
we can focus on the questions of having
the Attorney General giving of his time
this morning to be here to answer these
questions regarding the budget as you
know general barra the DNA forensic
science can speed the prosecution of the
guilty protect the innocent from
wrongful prosecution and exonerate the
wrongfully convicted mr. law office as
in prior years the DOJ is proposing to
use the fund available under the Debbie
Smith program for DNA analysis and
capacity enhancement along with quote
other local state and federal forensic
activities so long as sexual assault kit
backlogs persist I believe it's
important this funding be focused on DNA
analysis and capacity enhancement what
are some of the quote other local state
and federal forensic activities that are
funded under this Authority the National
Institute of Justice which is inside ojp
funds a program that strengthens the
medical examiner and corner systems
within our country in a variety way
supporting our forensics pathologists
and there's an alarming shortage of
pathologists across the country opioid
crisis has created a additional strain
due to overdose deaths so one of the
focuses of our grant money today is on
medical examiners and coroner's we also
provide grants directly to forensic
laboratories to encourage their research
and the focus of the grant is to make
sure that they have all the tools they
need to have effective forensic testing
and that has a real real impact on the
DNA back logs across the country if we
can help them with their technology we
can really reduce the backlog so that's
that's one of our key things we are
focused on we have a hundred and five
million dollars in this budget for DNA
related programs and we have forty seven
and a half million dollars to work
the backlog of the national sexual
assault kit initiative and we want to
make sure that that money is funded in
the budget because it's very important
to help to states and localities with
the sexual assault examinations and the
kits and make sure that is taken care of
so we believe we have a good solid
budget in this area to continue to work
on both the DNA and the sexual assault
kit areas let me switch over just a
minute to opioids of course that
epidemic continues to ravage communities
in my home state of Alabama and I know
you realize that fentanyl is 50 times
more potent than heroin heroin and
overdose deaths are on the rise with
fentanyl the president has called this a
national health crisis it's impacted
families and the future of this country
what would you say are some of the most
significant actions that the Department
of Justice has taken to curb the deadly
opioid epidemic that's plaguing the
country currently no look just fentanyl
or the whole opioid well you know both
are you know either one that you won't
address fentanyl there's recent there's
recently been a development as you know
most of the fentanyl and fentanyl
analogues come from China and the
Chinese have agreed to schedule all
fentanyl and phenyl analogs which would
which would make enforcement much easier
in China and we we would like to see a
comparable action here taken in the
United States to allow us to schedule
fentanyl keep phenol on the schedule and
all analogs of fentanyl that's a very
important step now whether the Chinese
action they actually deliver on it from
an enforcement standpoint remains to be
seen but it's something we've been
asking them to do and we're very pleased
that they've done it but generally
speaking in the opioid arena as you know
they're one of the main problems and
essentially the sort of the groundwork
for this epidemic was set by the abuse
of prescription drugs and the diversion
of prescription illicit
illicit drugs
and our a lot of our efforts are devoted
toward going after health care providers
and companies and others that
contributed to this by over-prescription
or permitting diversion and so there's a
lot of civil and criminal action around
the country there's going after these
bad actors and their task forces around
the country focused on that aspect of it
and so the first effort is to contract
the pool of people who are addicted by
licit drugs on the illicit drug front we
basically have a two-pronged strategy of
going after the talks the transnational
criminal organizations in Mexico
primarily in Mexico that are responsible
for most of these drugs coming into the
United States and also the local
distribution networks and we have the
FBI the DEA and a substantial portion of
our US Attorney's Office has focused on
dealing with these local distribution
networks and so that's that's basically
the strategy thank you are you back mr.
chairman mr. Jim I think it was our
congressman Chris was asking me about
the letters and whether anyone was
involved in the letters other than
people at justice and I checked with my
staff and was told that just before the
letters were out but after they were
finalized and just before they went out
we did advise the White House counsel's
office that the letters were being sent
but they were not allowed or even asked
to make any changes to the letters but
we did we gave them we notified them
before we issued them mr. Chris I'm sure
would have asked you did they get to see
the letter however I think it may have
been read to them they did not get to
see the letter thank you
it slowly mr. Attorney General I want to
get to some other items in the budget
today because under current law
background checks must be done within
three days of the transaction is allowed
to proceed
regardless of whether a person is
lawfully permitted to buy a gun my
judgment it is vitally important that
background checks are done thoroughly as
we know the results have been complete
information can be fatal for example we
know that the shooter who perpetrated
the Charleston shooting had passed a
background check
despite information that should have
disqualified him the house-passed
enhanced background checks Act
substantially increases the amount of
time allowed for a NICs background check
to ensure that we close these loopholes
I'm concerned that until this bill moves
through the Senate and onto the
President's desk that three days is not
often enough time to evaluate a
background check with questionable
information in your judgment with fewer
prohibited individuals be able to
purchase firearms if this time period
was extended the data that I have heard
is that they're about 6,000 of these
delayed responses the work where these
default sales occur after the expiration
of the three days and that when you go
back and look at those 6000
approximately 2,000 of those about a
third are people that would have flunked
the background check and their ATF goes
out and gets the weapon retrieves the
weapon I think it's fairly rare that
well I think that the Aurora shooter may
have been someone who got that default
that default sale that you know that it
was sold to them after the three-day
period so it does occasionally happen
wait a minute occasionally didn't you
mention two thousand six thousand well
they're not all shooters in other words
it does sometimes happen that somebody
support extending the time
I've had an interaction with so many
people in law enforcement and in many
cases three days it's shot it's just not
enough do you support extending the time
period no I think that you know that
puts a burden on a lot of people maybe
buying a gun that shouldn't have a gun
is that what you're saying when you're
saying it puts a burden on a lot of
people I think I should rather put a
burden on those who were doing the
investigation and I would put the
emphasis I would put the emphasis on
getting accurate records put into the
system and make sure that we're getting
all the records into the system I think
a far bigger problem is the is the
problem of mental health that is another
elephant in the room that's where all
these school shootings are arising from
and we have to figure out a way of
upgrading the next system so it actually
helps us to detect people with mental
illness that should not have have guns
and I think we should be investing in
NICs the accuracy of the records the
obligations of states to put those
records into the system and make that a
stronger not a stronger system one that
we can rely on that's where I would put
the effort I'm not sure what you mean by
a stronger system in other words if one
if your colleagues was doing a study and
looking at a background check and said I
need three more days do you feel that
person should have three more days two
more days six more days isn't it more
important to get a good thorough
background check and limiting the office
to three days what I was saying is that
the the better job we do of getting the
records into the system that we won't
have those three days you know that that
the level of a three day default sale I
mean you mentioned the sometimes federal
agencies are not putting the appropriate
records in as we saw you know with the
Air Force situation sometimes state
agencies are not putting the records in
so there are gaps in the records let me
go on that's a formal important thing
let me go onto the next question I do
hope we can continue this conversation
another time you have referred to the
Violence Against Women Act as a bad idea
and not in the legitimate interests of
the federal government these are
investments that fund services for
victims of domestic abuse and sexual
assault that many of my constituents
including those trapped in cycles of
domestic violence and looking for a way
out rely on under Republican leadership
in the previous Congress maybe I'll just
wait a minute the authorization of the
Violence Against Women Act was allowed
to expire despite bipartisan support
thankfully last week the reauthorization
passed the House again with bipartisan
support during your confirmation hearing
you change your position and supported
vawa's programs pledging to familiarize
yourself with the offices work and its
program I was delighted to hear that so
I'd be interested in knowing whether you
support the reauthorization of VAWA and
do you support the house-passed
reauthorization bill I do I do support
the reauthorization of Violence Against
Women Act I'm not sure about the House
bill and what's in it but I do support
the reauthorization of that provision
let me just say that to the extent I
said something against the Violence
Against Women statute I believe that
that was in the context of it when
originally came up you know two and a
half decades ago or 30 years ago
somewhere in that range and what I said
was that 'men that point it was a
substantive law relating to the penalty